the 2017 world championship group stage
has come to a close and it was a wild
one to watch so let's take a look back
at the best plays were kicking off our
list with a demon king himself with his
1v2 out play against cloud nine is he
gonna take a good bite Marines we have
to bare their teeth and wait for a few
more minutes no way is legendary but
still Giga Byte Marines they're not
quite strong enough to end the game so
as though just feeding fuel into the
fire recoger called a double drug that's
the triple he's looking for the
quadruplets wow that's a good come out
no way is hoping for it they will attend
is there
we'll be able to hold on beautiful play
from pathetic play on the topside trick
is here perks is here they have the
point click CC they can't keep this
going banging arms on the way but I
don't even think they're going to need
it
they are parting tool at me but stealing
is coming in the double jump it happens
to this to setup an ability to straight
off our ml XG 3 K trough that all T is
going to go and who's going to take it
out of the end she twos gonna get it and
they get out with style
Malcolm's dolphin goes the hook maker
gonna land the double knocked up
staggers blur brings him in trying to 1
B 1 dendiface kitty trying to come back
Jensen's running for his life he might
just get clapped he's bringing himself
out to safety fake you're gonna run get
down there they're gonna turn the top
and try to push out arch even get away
with this flame getting a bit low the
flash the time gonna be there as well
they might have the first name of a beer
beyond death
back in Jolla gets the kilt credit
unluckily for them wow look at the man
from behind
SKT are good but when they went down 10k
and goals against EDG not many thought
that they would have a chance of taking
the game that was until this insane
wombo combo three carry champion from
the it's the double Club
just don't leave us Justin he's gonna
grab the triple concert taking a lot of
heat but he lives just barely by a
shield from smoothie and impact and one
fight is all
[Applause]
crowd laughs did you live with high fees
as it were
all right caso prison again their lab is
gonna spot them out just in time
our boys got himself to already be caged
for mouses dick goes down to scout
somehow a solar kill Suzie did you've
got the triple team weg a is having a
fantastic tournament and it's solo kills
like this that have solidified him among
the best mid laners in the world nine
five seven missed timing the knock upon
power of evil at GA looking for the 1v1
Kenny I'll play the ultimate Isola doubt
he Kavitha my have this curtain probably
the most effective guy in the entire
game so far captain Vince spell shield
fear comes out red buck is taking caps
running for his life will be by should
be able to burn this out dust breaker
find them in the brush TSM still moving
exactly as a unit getting themselves
away power of evil looking for the
damage on to Han sir or bjergsen splits
his fire a little bit haunts are nearly
taking out the heel to keep them alive
to the ignite but it is not enough
instant to be able to boot down as well
up in the top lane solo kill for zip at
the top lane oh there we got against the
flash over beautifully done to get that
extra 5 a.m. and I steal the am pissed
there's one other one I feel like my
favor SKT siege I might need their tank
do any actually happy to keep fighting
impact putting more and more damage
across that a half HP on the maokai not
freaking witness battle of duel
continues though the health bar getting
down below hopper look at that man
powered shot glass over yoga
and I are still take live
leading our list of the best turnarounds
from the group stage is this
unbelievable play by TSM to reverse a
gank on bjergsen power people snuck into
this part this is a very good sneak
Nixon doesn't have his flash remember he
had to use it last time and now he's
going to be jumped on the damage coming
through of a pile cross keeps him alive
it walks away
Michelle leaves at the convent it now
has an opening closing the mega happens
and staff good fun for that phone it up
Jensen gonna grab the first flood we
have hit level 6 on Chet as well so the
opportunity to go straight in the tower
aggro bullet ready first light he is
stealth up that's gonna be first blood
for the twitch down in some trouble here
I have a difficult time getting himself
away has to take the cat
next Jerry gashes don't wanna be number
one in trouble can't fly class over here
they
take them out mouth from the kid similar
jump away but Jenna's goes is out come
from Cali all
again just one now trying to find the
Tong under reckless for the nice
sidestep comes through even wants to
make it a safe trg-42 for novices the
middle of a team that's a bet casted now
reckless into trouble no way has no fair
and dependents it's gonna get dropped
down he's look at the floor
that's gonna be the shut down at the
triple Baron open mosasaurs
fun is fun it happens cat slows down a
poster once in tonight's to get
deliveries videos cue but he's got to
run out of places ago the flats
available here comes they have it yes
the two first blood two games in a row
she's straight back into the middle now
maybe wanted to be the silly you know
does keep in my life for a little bit
longer bring up get a try and dive in a
gorilla try to find the tape but don't
cry make fun get the great healthy downs
of trapped in minutes gorilla will die
optimist knowing does have flash he
comes back around those fifty in the fog
land spotty some notes or no there is to
Rebecca takes one shot under for the
ball but there's the damage at put and
they're gonna get first blood coming
through the rib prison in time Beltre
come Tarasco a plane could be trapped in
this one TV in there fly MCS we're both
we gonna try and save it down this plane
goes get the Noma the roster room good
academic troublesome but if it a great
switch refuge come protect them for long
enough flame get the kill right here
nice stun gonna land they're gonna look
for the bulb we're on a cousin to come
across almost going down somebody he'll
comes through for BT to keep alive down
the backlight so
cutaway because the damage ah hey and
friggin a knock him down and here comes
the next one Jensen flick to the falls
well v2d grabbing himself another one
now I can look at the parents do another
knock up they want to see his charcoal
someone he went to land of there's
almost no way out for him
Davis given across it yet they find away
mediums go through the barrier in as
well during the Janice shield regardless
and I was in the front line a little bit
isolating the first day was coming
across as impact cards are coming as
well as looking for on and yes the tank
is gone already
pulls them back in with an R that's
wallop there as well and Jensen is
around but look at the mini-map they'd
support coming down to use the
collateral damage to get even further
away contacts takes down mouse to look
at cloud9 downloads if this one is
applied back down
Jensen justice do so so risky no regard
for Kelly is gonna head towards about
site that's gonna be thought her going
in let me comes as well as I said they
cannot stop each other in that range
Natha and the rest of the damage coming
in from Uzi and let me the group stage
was full of fantastic team fights so to
start off check out this incredibly
close exchange between long shoe and
fanatics teleport looks to get a knock
upon the frame USSS they're gonna quit
not even to the inn for a while but he's
got the shoes got to stay alive no
killaby hat and the front line gonna be
open up of attaches the first kill he's
on a spree from self reckless stops to
grab the red buff his open he's now down
the block the flash part a double kill
so far for a servant on the meter
looking for caps can be beaten a chains
to come down gets prevent for the ladies
paisa tray to kill for Suez by the
bottom half time Roxas stayin alive ah
here comes Connie ones this one does the
damage exist he's got okey that's gonna
be a counter praxis gets knocked back
pop the other they have the damage no he
doesn't the ACE comes through two
members alive we didn't have did this
could be the game closing fight that one
back jingim done a treat on ready
spray-and-pray coming out to members
locked up on to the kill squad staff now
trying to turn this one back there mayor
the EEC is in trouble because the switch
is just for his campaign but said
take it down loosen going in moving
forward triple kill but not enough
cuatro comes in for twitch in the end
take the free out of truck the biggest
sector the makeup flashing do not come
but now it's gonna be Scouts
[Applause]
booties on the run EDG looking to finish
them off the righteous glory pop elbows
are knockout drops I boys stands alone
and they're gonna try and do as much
damage as possible but once again Caza
get itself stones Olaf gets himself out
of the way has caught up with the only
remedy there
we're gonna try and reset not Spenlow
even not desert our government
he's getting secured the thief I win MMD
down one Nexus turret gone TSM have to
make their fight with the flashing
photonic behind beerus and he's going to
go down soon he grabbed the guild of BOE
but he still fought two verses for
misfits still look at the ending awnser
needs to find his way on the hots olive
I can't quite do it another big talk
about Lorelai but affari drums instead
punch Tama on the run Nexus turret still
standing
TSM reinforcements arrived try some -
she's going for fight instead or a slew
begins looking to pick off a munchies
white tank the whole team is here ready
to find a pickle - the truck with me the
bear but he's going to make it out the
back side the assassin swish expect has
something to say but he's already out of
the fight if it knocks back that is a
massive win coming in for orangey perks
firing back to the side of G - bo is
spent already dead
there's not a lot of options left
he's cleaning up house he's looking for
a triple klutz out who's the one to
bring nobody off the founders thought it
let me come to put behind you the MLS
use here is done the frontline cowfish
go put Steven Hauk the camp beats to the
pet redemptions their back but Barrett
is dropping but no one is
six-pack needs to go back a bath too
little too late
get out
the prize patient with his ultimate if
HQ does go too far in banks can open up
Baker I'll smash blank alpha that they
both return a bucket he only comes out
that he once it on but the damages good
bank up back in zip not going to peel
the fins up through the 50 pence enemies
hounds are now fake up get a dye pack in
and beats the ultram jolly bank up so
good at this game
th es summons on the court
Michigan attract
[Applause]
gets out of the way nine stacks no
champions that he's looking for some
dinner
three-two-three care team w e feather
storm start from mystic cosmic radiance
those down it's going to get just a few
of the members she gaze on the backside
I'm protected and that may be the focus
sponsor heads up through the entire team
collapses she aged out Ben tries to run
out of here missed again the top side
the beautiful damage coming in from him
the focus is perfect sets Gary low bow
front goes in for another attack mm has
found the reset and he says here we go
TSM TSM find themselves the ACE they rip
through team w e marshals want to fight
him flash wolves gonna be using that to
me to come in start this one off bid in
some danger Conde look at the body
blocks trying to get him out of there if
he can but the talk husband and cars is
grabbing the kiddo now seeing if they're
able to find the FAMAS on the mystic but
he's the la piel all the pain today more
auto attacks might be able to do it but
now mystic gonna be jumped on by the
Shaq Conybeare the kill on the car stop
galio comes into the cavalry charge as
maple goes into the backline going after
Conde now as well the old lake down one
more transfuse could grab the kill
what a bloodbath and out log the fight
get a half moon nine five seven started
the ball and he's walked up this far
still defending this time 5.0 there's
low health bars that he could pop up GA
and 9 5 7 but I take down this turret
potentially grab the kill and a maple as
well
lots of damage coming out for these 280
solo laners the wind comes through they
don't find the mark she ain't gonna be
taken out he's got to be careful got a
debate at the kill nine five seven
trying to get something here he will
find Betty we're not getting there for
the fanatic possibly in fashion again
they over front them because they have
the damage of a will so a small plane
through to the trippity pumpkins don't
play stayin alive little bit longer a
pig free man shot right there pulling
back on the leg to get the first kill
breakfast get out when a train is what
Mark comes in hit the bot Lane the
support going down 3v for immortals
clusters run away but fnatic they want
this one the chase Porter probably not
quick the blade color range and just
barely missing onto that Miami this
still more to be done to look for the
kill grandma's gonna come in and props
together to kill threat of that one in a
flash
but they're just gonna proof that those
actually you know let's make it a great
way now if I keep the way say them they
can to my charity goes out the reckless
no it needs to stay alive in this fight
Brooks are chunks by optimist but so I'm
just going to get the guilt auntie left
out the dry as well but Rickson he's
gonna be the target punches I does
multi-gender sir who get Peter is my way
moves in there just get they kill water
chaotic five ultimate actually trying to
bait them in record little Foofa boy
with Sam
banks up still going Burnside mega be
told anybody Gus
oh no fanatic inching closer doctor been
getting it taken down by the veteran
super minions in the mid wave after that
after the elder Drake see laughter no
way killing reckless it looks like
fanatic will be going to go to final
it's not an eighth just yet but SARS
will ensure it will be but the Beretta
p5
and am still trying to find the bike
gorilla go static chat too often
now God blessing into the old
yeah that frozen mallet not really hurt
RG two bunches nothing even saved it
damn it Jim it's another two men talk
breyfogle attacking his cause foolish
we spoke to the GM but that's not an
hour to miss cutler by the locomotives
get the girl
but the markup on this saying no way on
the other side better phone's automatic
on so they carried you need to try and
find it out here but a great position in
belongs you know it to the damaged ripto
doing quite a gorilla can get a pole but
I thought that didn't everybody decent
and that's the kill won't shoot I think
they've just barely done it oh my
goodness aren't she's gonna go down as
well BDD though last take not enough
twins up Wilma take down the rise
teleport promote out there is not be
good joy memorials what's the choice are
they gonna go now Elsa
my birth but they can still fight
another big Russians in the back of the
fight Frank shut down by dirty bud
Rosco dusting up boy before the fun is
continuing BDD still here let's knock
off mines Kirti and won't you turn it
around
what a crazy fight coming around TP Joe
Kamui here comes paper on the back.this
Babu can he find the Sharks an affine
barrier from Jensen the fight continues
if you look for the kill the vendors
getting close
he's gonna be a treat he gets one we're
just for the fun of the class continue
and who'd he gives himself a second kill
as the carries from cloud nine armed all
God has doubles out out of Mooney shot
glass gets the kill two spoons the
bottle has got nice little shot at a
conference what's the fight they're
looking for wild comes down survived a
mission cloud nine needy Geno Everton in
Iraq Clara is the only sacrifice iBook
continues tequila and stout is sitting
on the front line gets himself another
taun mouse down 200 HP running for his
life
Scout gets a gigantic shield jumps back
in with a justice punch a little too
overeager for EVG brown dwarf now might
be enough to close it out cloud nine
trying to turn around
throws out the overload after overload
spell flux comes down in the room prison
Jensen takes our maker and cloud nine
survive to live another day a small
window to secure a major objective is
still going straight into the middle
trick cannot flash out of this he's put
himself right in expect rise the flash
they want the fight now before FB
contenders pudding crashes down that's
frozen as well as a pony fall mat and
trying to kite back to do what he can
but it's Thoren falling in front of him
and without the captain without the rest
of the team it's going to be difficult
I wanna call your mother box you in
their traps and we'll take the Nexus be
more Hanson
javante now in the middle fight hits the
battle dance back the pattern looks like
em LF she wants three but he goes down
then favor of patent child who take a
turn shot mm does the same as he goes
down Vayne is gonna get that kill if he
picks one enough
let me chomps down onto my water
the exit for paddock it's gonna look
pretty gay 1,700 HBO the inferno
come to the to man doctor yet comes the
heroes into soldiers
able to call the feathers back it's
absent galaxy just ruining FB thumbs and
sitting on the front line patent gets
caught up by the rupture force to run
away he's dodging dipping ducking and
diving he comes out to attack enough
except some why 15 minutes probably
gonna knock down this shirt is very low
but even on behalf of not a nutbar
respond to the back okay take a little
bit more flex in the front and bjergsen
drop the double three on Misfits dead
already enigma he's gonna be the next
one man get a full s Katie's last second
elder dragon steel and team fight win
against AHQ kick off our list of pit
plays from the group stage otherwise you
will react over atomic age very big play
a double-kill Burbank Charlie gonna die
down as well SKT kill it all from a spot
in the quarterfinals to chase down a
very nice butt so it's gonna stay around
and try to get the bird Thomas goes down
to Cody and immortals take the objective
[Applause]
last but not least the group stages best
death brushes tower dives and level 1
invades
are all up next
another Hill SKT Finn later Scout to be
taken low
[Applause]
Pina is forced back as hoody has to run
away as well
[Applause]
hi take this little brush here glory but
there's no way out of that he has the
realm orbit they could go for this
trundle is box just gonna be in range
expect to get the few chops down himself
they want to die a great welcome rough
day hit the poor man died from fanatical
a Nutella tomato didn't get the
direction right rough stuff just to be
able to get it at a time is good but too
reckless jezus yeah both perky up with
the wall as well he's gonna start riding
it so it could be in trouble he doesn't
his but he's gonna try and go down the
way not quite enough barbells up grab
it's a kill but they might get beated in
here looks like Capps is planning a
surprise overlooks birth of Julia he's
gonna maybe get away
reckless unstoppable with the poisonous
brushed up takedown Cody phonetic pick
up the duo Lane meanwhile of truth they
want to kill that Park Lane run for a
turret dive goes level one here we go if
they can do it the real is able to find
the knock of the demon come out they
grab the first blow the Archie and bacon
two logs you is setting up
that's why more school bus-train
interruption prey gets hit he's able to
jump out to shop arrives to come out
behind here who's got the follow-up
damage and it goes out there gorilla
this is going to be the warm I'll
teleport Anton
so but it's been about yet going for an
ebay trying to shake things up they feel
they need to make something happen early
if they can get the upper hand your
glitter Lance through the entire team
MLS you fast-forward bars are damaged
from before one more shotgun a lot gonna
come in it goes to crash on his jungle
Nidalee over the ball and it's out who
their be scared
I started up they find out
Ben is not out yet he's leaving a safety
get down and air so notch I'm so as fine
secure get three minute knock up but
already leave I go down and K Nanoha
cheese good to be in trouble damage
still laying in but so it can't land the
rupture again but he will pull off the
flash so I push port alone reckless has
no flash oh my goodness the knuckle does
went in no that's [ __ ] Doug Lancer
the support grabs him he invaded orbit
to pray off she's gonna get a good on my
BDD that's actually everybody coming in
all right well I see how much time keep
me by quiet a lot although he does go
down be needy for quick limbs in the
midlane slash still available for fake
ass let's see for the CC comes from is
the permafrost as well chum the waters
tax from a good distance first direct
store I still want to see the impact in
an actual team fights with this bill
from oh they caught caught when he
brings this shark back in the checks in
one kill comes through to the blast away
this could still be dangerous bigger
pops gazillions think you find of in
split that one wasn't in range of much
but here comes the backside active demos
run away
with smoothies already dead Jensen next
Emma to teach I'm Linda grasp the kill
now on the bigger but he pops away he's
gonna say live with him when they can't
quite fall yet one does them good
impacts for plant the tough way there's
only three of them it feels like it's a
pressure hurricane be about to through
their beautiful howling gale into the
last breath that's the head on to padded
they just used quite a bit in the top
lane for that fight so his ultimate was
not up constantly deleted by maple
they're playing the bushwhack game and
they found misfits wandering around in
the jungle of it as where flash wolves
catapult himself in the lead and now
he's got a good position here actually
it's gonna happen big damage from honey
he's got no flaps oh no way out
secure for clear love in front of his
hometown look as your phone is there
such a great game alright [ __ ] be
engaged with the quickness manages to
get a bottle up knock up going to answer
but cheat you are the ones in the old
village in town
crowd takes him out trip it's next on
the list they'll adjust to get let's bow
take submission over the wall at the
tower not gonna be enough to kill this
time around
yeah means there's a world where towards
the top lane they can try and get in
these go through the tower great stone
gonna permafrost it up as all rocks are
not gonna be in here horns are gonna try
and maybe flush away its own thing he
can do it rip up warmer sand up he
punches out MacArthur you want top of
them really nice a ward there a call
from Casa TVs coming in Betty does take
up I brush too much still somehow alive
and kapha he's gonna chase him down and
take him down spent will make that same
face they're losing the entire evil wave
they're actually losing so much from
here that one little good news here but
there's the snap coming down by for us
needs to move back in to try and take
that top of the chip but he gets hooked
up by Tina people still dressed in a
virus not gonna make it that's burst
blood flame stuck all the way back
around flame musicals little bit further
forward has now finally found four
records who's gonna force the bus he has
it he does follow through flame wasn't
looking back with that is not enough
reckless gets the kill caps he's got
nothing left no all those understand
microfiber
turn flashes
it's great from stop look through so
many rocks and that is not gonna be
enough to get the kill rabbit just go
down records against cookie for the
fight on the program that takes him down
listen they got scouted that last time
they did it but now they see oh here we
go
whoa but their classes over the ball
Cody flashes over the wall thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button